you are watching the press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive
it's time to see what's making the
headlines with steve richards and
sal michelle they'll be with us right
through
until midnight they're smiling now let's
hope they will still be smiling
at that late hour so let's see what's
coming up on the front of those
newspapers for you now the daily
telegraph reports that 32
million britons will be offered booster
covered vaccines at the start of next
month
in the hope of completing the rollout by
christmas
pay for your own heart op writes the
daily mail the paper says growing
numbers of patients are paying for
life-saving surgery
because of nhs waiting lists
heroes star tyrone ming's covers the
front of the sun
as he talks about the personal mental
health problems
he faced during the tournament
the times reports tory backbenchers and
the travel industry are pushing back
against travel restrictions
the financial times report signs of
housing fever as the pandemic pushes up
prices and the metro focuses on team
gb's olympic success featuring pictures
of bmx star charlotte worthington and
gymnastics champion
max whitlock
stephen selma with me now to take us
through those newspapers good evening to
you both let's start with the
daily telegraph on their front page
there the headline booster shots for
32 million begin next month these are
booster shots of the
vaccine for uh kevin 19 but at the same
time we're also aware that the the
government is
desperately trying to get younger people
to even have the first shot
steve yeah you feel this is a sort of
again
a moment on a kind of hinge in this
never-ending covered drama uh
on the upbeat side i think it is
encouraging
and sensible to prepare for these
booster jabs
and it does show the degree to which
rightly
uh the government sees the vaccines as
the way
through this the sort of liberating path
if you like
and that therefore uh the booster jab
will be something i think
largely taken up because i think in the
telegraph it says they're going to
target the over
50s so that's one second as you say
there's still the
ongoing situation of younger people
not taking up the jab different motives
being talked about
to encourage them to get second vaccines
or first vaccines
so you've got two different threads here
how are you going to
make sure that by september
most of the uk is vaccinated and then
what are you going to do
to make sure the protections continue
into the next really testing phase of
the autumn
and the winter and we know it's the
testing phase because we all lived
through it
last year yes indeed and some of the the
article is is confirming that it's all
adults
aged 50 and over as well as the immuno
suppressed and they'll be offered the
booster jabs and that could start
as soon as that september the 6th but it
just seems as
though this will be a different rollout
because it's mentioning
um that uh 2000 pharmacies will
be involved so it doesn't seem as though
they're going to have the
the math centers that we've had for the
the first and second job
no and i think this is interesting
because what it means is that the
government is actually establishing
a much more permanent way of actually
bringing vaccines out on a mass scale in
the same way that you would do with the
flu vaccination
and i think that was always supposed to
be part of the government's plan so
i actually find that quite reassuring um
that this is what's going to happen and
you can walk into your pharmacy
because the infrastructure is there to
be able to get the covered vaccination
in the same way that you would
any other um i also think that you know
time is really of the essence here and
if the government's still
struggling to get you know younger
people vaccinated than their right to
try and focus on those people who are
going to be vulnerable
over the winter period because you know
as steve said we all remember what this
was like last year and even though
there's
positive tones um at the moment around
infection numbers
we cannot uh risk you know going
backwards on this so it's
um it's quite reassuring steve take us
out
to the daily mail and their front page
at uh first reading of this headline it
does seem quite shocking pay for your
own heart
op well this is the other side
of the copic coin the waiting lists that
have
grown not just kobe but the tendency to
underfund the nhs compared
with other equivalent countries and
their health provision
the combination of the two means there
are these epic
waiting lists for non-covid treatments
so what do you do now according to the
mail those with the money are throwing
money
at the situation and spending a fortune
on things like heart hops so the
headline it's not a sort of new
government policy
go out and pay for your own heart off
but it's a consequence
of the huge demand and the lack of
capacity
and um i think the kind of lack of
capacity issue
the long waiting list is going to become
a growing
political issue over the autumn and into
next year because to meet it will
involve inevitably substantial increases
in resources and staff and it's not at
all clear
that they will be in place quickly
enough to address it
hence the front page of the mail
tomorrow
yes and some of those without the
financial means will be at a real
disadvantage with with the hard
operation costing
according to the mail on average they're
20 000 pounds
i mean hugely and i i don't think the
suggestion is that it's just people who
can afford it i think it's people who
are desperate
and that's the reason why there is this
uh surge in in private
um in private treatment i think the
issue here
again just to go back to you know the
question of booster jabs and coming out
of
uh restrictions is exactly this that we
have this huge
problem that is occurring with waiting
lists that is not covert related
and i think the department for health
has is trying now to message us in a way
um to ensure that we don't think of this
as the national covid service and
we think of it as the national health
service again and i think that's very
important in people
for people to understand that they
actually can come forward with other
illnesses in a way that during you know
the height of the pandemic
um they were told to stay away so i hope
that you know the department of health
sort of thinks about how they're
messaging this stuff as well uh let's
move on to
um talk about holidays everyone's
thinking can they take them where can
they go
um if they go will will rules be changed
while they're away and we've only really
got sort of august really of the
proper holiday season but it seems as if
um back bench
tories and actually cabinet ministers
rishi sunaka of one has been mentioned
are really putting a lot of pressure on
the prime minister to change his tact on
on the travel situation
steve well he's probably he's probably
putting pressure
on himself because he's inclined to open
up
whenever the uh whenever there's a
debate about this he's on the opening up
side it does seem weird
that on one level the uk or certainly
england
compared to quite a few countries sort
of opened up inverted commas
a couple of mondays ago and yet it's
travel restrictions
compared to some european countries for
example
are still pretty strict there's a sort
of odd
mismatch there now i think there's a
debate about whether they
opened up too much within england
to take the example of the
westminster-based government
uh too quickly and too early but given
that they did
it does seem weird the travel
restrictions
are still pretty constrained i suspect
there will be quite an
opening up in the coming days on that
front
but but one of the issues is that it's
just so complex
we're talking about this new amber watch
list now or amber plus as some people
have dubbed it
it's just incredibly complicated for
people isn't it selma
well not only is it incredibly
complicated but you actually can't
plan for anything with this system
because you know
i had a holiday book to france and all
of a sudden it went on amber plus plus
so i ended that
holiday and then spain looked like it
was going to be safe so we were thinking
about booking spain but that
that looks like it's gonna go into the
amber plus plus system
and i think the difficulty here is that
there isn't any clear communication
about what is prompting uh certain
countries to go on certain lists
and i think we had the foreign secretary
um saying something that was then
corrected about
you know the island of reunion uh being
the reason that france is on the amber
plus plus list
and whether there was a variant of
concern um in the country
so i i actually don't understand the
logic behind some of these decisions
so i think that is that is the other
complication to this is that nobody can
actually plan anything
no the whole traffic light system is in
sort of chaos if you remember
at the beginning uh those on the
so-called amber list
uh were not meant to be even considered
for
holidays or anything else it was for
kind of urgent work-related
travel well now amber you know
august because oh ambulance yeah that's
that might be possible
so the whole thing lacks clarity and
consistency
and coherence um and obviously as you
said at the beginning
uh we're this is august the first we're
in the key month now
this is when it really applies um
let's have a look at the ft to start
with it in this section and this is
story about
property prices um surging because of
the the pandemic how so steep
well the demand continues to outstrip
supply in so many uh key areas
and you have this problem whereby as
property prices saw in kind of cities
around
large parts of the world actually um
kind of essential workers
uh for example required for the pandemic
find it increasingly difficult to rent
or buy
in cities in particular as just one
example
and i think the issue of housing is
going to be a huge issue with the
uk as it already is um
it's going to be i think is going to
intensify
here and in other parts of um certainly
the western world in the coming
in the coming years as well yes uh
the article saying fastest u.s growth in
uh 30
years it is a global um phenomena that
they describe selma
yeah it's a global phenomenon because
obviously we've all
felt the pandemic and we've all gone
through lockdown
i think what's interesting is you know
the uk is in a unique position as well
because like other countries
um it sort of modified uh economic
stimulus
and one of that was one of those was
stamp duty in this
country and so i think that there are
things that the government has done
that's actually
um boosted this which you know in short
term makes sense
um to try and stimulate the housing
market when you think it's going to
stagnate
but it's going to remain to be seen as
to whether that was the right thing to
do
and the right stimulus to offer at the
time because if we're going to see
inflating prices
either we're going to see a bubble or
we're going to see a long period where
people are going to be again locked out
of buying
homes and the affordability will become
a lot more difficult steve let's have a
look at the
sun and this is the story of tyrone
ming's talking about his mental health
struggle
uh during the the euros uh being very um
honest about uh what what are you
going through yeah i mean i've been
seeing the front page
headline but isn't it interesting that
now
so many sporting stars it's been a
running theme of the olympics
not only feel the need to talk about uh
mental health pressures with the kind of
high profile the competitive pressures
and all the rest of it
not only feel the need but kind of do it
in a way that makes front page
headlines and on the whole though i have
some reservations it's a wholly positive
thing
because if these glamorous sports people
are doing it it absolutely breaks the
taboo and you know it wasn't that long
ago when very few were talking about
mental health
issues and now uh you're getting these
kind of superstars
doing it so it is good but there are
many other levels to it
it raises issues about the pressure put
upon these relatively young people
and whether the preparations are given
to them to cope with it and all the rest
of it
so i haven't read the details of this
but here we have another example
of the olympics and it does yes it does
raise a number of other
issues as you say with naomi osaka and
simone balls
as well those coming forward and happy
to discuss their
issues thank you both we shall see you
again
at 11 30.